what's the one thing that men face is
ability to get it up and then the
thought process of trying to get it up
makes it worse don't think about it babe
don't think about it it'll just happen
okay you don't want me to think about it
now now all i can do is think about it
right so it's kind of the same thing if
a woman wants to have an orgasm and you
and like that's all they're thinking
about and then they think oh crap well
i'm not it's not i'm doing it right is
it happening right is he enjoying it am
i enjoying it should i be doing this
yes yes that's such a good analogy
zacky boy welcome back
thanks for having me back
sooner than we planned man
yeah but it's it feels right too much to
talk about right so here's the first
thing i want to talk about chris rabb
from philadelphia
he has created a bill requiring men to
get vasectomies by age 40.
state representative chris rabb of
philadelphia democrat supports a
solution to law making men who want to
control policy on women's and girls
bodies require requiring men by six
weeks into age 40 or after child 3 to
get vasectomies and it's all in the name
of reproductive rights for women and
girls rob also wrote the legislation
which was in a response to restrictive
abortion bills around the us i thought
it was as important as a man to speak up
about reproductive rights rabb said
according to whp tv
there are bills and laws that regulate
and restrict bodily autonomy for women
and girls but not so much for men while
the legislation is satirical it's
supposed to add conversation on
reproductive rights
in the statement rabb said as long as
the state legislature continues to
restrict the reproductive rights of cis
men as cis women trans men and
non-binary people there should be laws
to address the responsibility of men who
impregnate them that's obviously beside
the law of having to look after the
child and pay child support for the
first 18 years of its life
my sincere hope in introducing this
legislation is that my colleagues in the
general assembly consider the
egregiously gendered double standard
when it comes to curtailing reproductive
health care as it applies to women
republicans reportedly responded with
abortion and vasectomies not being equal
issues and argued the bill conversation
won't get very far what do you think
about that
so
the the main thing that i heard from and
and what i want to talk about is the
satirical aspect of it so like it was
knowingly satirical right when he did it
he
so he himself knows that it's not ever
going to get passed and it's not real so
what i'm wondering is what is the
efficacy of like an extreme
satirical
play like that
to get conversation started
well ultimately right like to to get
people thinking about you know the other
side of it which is
the um
abortion laws that are being passed it's
it's very interesting obviously it's
ridiculous right he even knows it's
ridiculous
um
but that's what i'm i'm wondering is
like how how effective is satire
in bringing about conversation and i
would say it's decently effective right
you have um well we're talking about it
yeah exactly and and what sort of effect
will it have on the actual lawmakers and
the uh you know the people in power who
can
you know make a difference and and make
changes i don't know if i want the
people that represent me in government
to be wasting time and money
doing [ __ ] like this though that just
yeah
is that the satire no matter how [ __ ]
effective it is it needs to be
unbelievably effective because he's put
a bill in i don't i have no idea yeah
it's waste of time yeah but he's created
a bill and it's actually been
put out into the world
is there not more important things to do
your country's [ __ ]
like the government and the politicians
i
a guy is basically trolling at like the
elite level professional trolling yeah
yeah yeah i mean i'd rather
you know tax dollars go elsewhere for
sure
for sure than that and that
it's a it's insane um
but you know here we are talking about
it
yeah fair point i also
i don't know i feel like
trying to
further restrict
in response to a restriction
is just a bad
uh it's not a tremendously good way to
try and even the scales right if you
have a problem with a particular law
let's say it's restrictions on voter id
you don't then try and restrict
something else to even the scales you
try to reduce the restriction that
you've got a problem with and the same
thing goes with abortion law like if
you're bothered about the restrictions
on abortions then
you can fight that but trying to create
something that sits on the opposite side
of the fence it makes it too easy if he
genuinely cared i think there would have
been a smarter way to go about this
because it's not it's not the same it's
not equivalent it would it would be the
same as a woman getting her tubes tied
which right isn't the same as an
abortion
yeah
that doesn't match up
for me at all really restricting
someone's ability to reproduce
um and then the other one is
you know the person has already
reproduced yeah and then you're right
taking a life which is what the
people that are pro-life are arguing
that bit about uh there should be laws
to address the responsibility of men who
impregnate women it's like what do you
mean like there already are
yeah there's um
you have to pay for the child
there's child support yeah for a very
long time already exist anyway that's
that's what i've been thinking about
this week
yeah that's it's that's incredibly odd
it sounds like it would be a headline to
an onion article
[Laughter]
right
wouldn't it be i mean like
i i honestly when you brought it up i
i've never heard of this but when you
brought it up i thought it was like a uh
like a population control type of play
like like china
for quite a while yeah you know so [ __ ]
it what you've been thinking about
well um i've been thinking about
jon jones um
he has he's gotten in trouble again this
time he was abusing his wife he's got
for for those who are listening who
don't know who jon jones is maybe you
don't know martial arts he's
you know considered one of the best
martial artists like really of all time
which is which is crazy um he's in the
ufc hasn't been active in a long time
and
he's a very very troubled individual and
he just
recently uh was elected or
not elected um
hall of fame right he was he was
inducted yes inducted into the hall of
fame for one of his fights i can't
remember which would you know off it was
the one with gustafson okay so
um he had just gotten his award he
you know went back to the hotel told his
wife that yeah in vegas of course that
actually really matters in this one okay
so in vegas told his wife hey i'm gonna
go out i'm taking ten thousand dollars
uh i'm gonna go out
comes back they get in an argument at
like five in the morning he hits her she
goes down to the lobby the security
guard notices the blood on her face
because she asks to change
the room right it was a cry for help it
was a well she that's actually true she
didn't want to go back to the room with
him
i think she wanted a different or wait
did she want to lock him out i think she
wanted to lock him out so by changing
the room key he wouldn't have been able
to get back in and she went down and the
one of the daughters was there with her
yes and i think you know that also could
have been like a hey i'm
i'm in trouble like i'm scared type of
thing
also right it's
she said the wife said can we just get a
new room key and the guy mentioned do
you need
any assistance and she kind of said no
but she also said that she didn't want
to go back up and then it was the
daughter
the daughter was the one that said can
you call the police
right yes yes [ __ ]
i know that was that i think that was
the the chill video that you sent me
that was the
the part that really
it makes their heads on the back of your
neck stand up like yeah your own
daughter
is calling the police on you to stop you
from hitting her mother
yeah like so crazy so he's a very very
very troubled man and we can talk about
like
you know what he should do or shouldn't
do or what should happen
but something that's very interesting to
me is
um
this was something that
daniel cormier who's now uh you know an
analyst and
uh you know just uh a figurehead at the
ufc
um
he was a uh heavyweight champion or
super heavyweight champion uh in the ufc
i don't know he defended it a couple
times he lost the belt got it back
but um
he had a few fights with jon jones and
one of the things that he said in his
interview
he ended up kind of predicting the
future and i'll just play the clip um
i'll play the audio here i want to hear
my reaction please he doesn't want to
hear my reaction because i will tell him
some sobering truth please sober in
truth is his history dictates and
determines
that the same thing thing's gonna happen
that is his character that is him at his
core i look at that young lady the pr
lady that's on his team now and i see in
her eyes she knows she's fighting a
losing battle i look at his coaches i
see that these guys know that this kid
will not change he won't he will not
change he's the same guy he's rotting at
his core and he will continue
don't you think that people can learn
from their mistakes mistakes
mistakes
you don't constantly make mistakes no
you make mistakes but you don't do them
over and over and over and over and over
you don't do that because you know what
a mistake when you make a mistake it
changes you try to make yourself better
and this many times we've heard this
speech jonathan pretty unbelievable that
gave me the chills so that was i believe
two years ago
and john had already been in a lot of
trouble and
dc says he's rotten at his core and he
is bound to repeat history will repeat
itself with this man
and look at what we're doing we're
talking about this
i thought that that was the most
effective like i i have not seen
something like that that would to me
that was chilling
and what i wanted to talk about
with you chris is
what
well i guess first let's talk about
redemption for someone like jon jones
and my theory is that he has to almost
he has to let go of his identity
completely
he has to do penance you know whatever
that is if he has to go to jail whatever
that is you know
um if that's monetary
but he has to lose his identity as a
fighter and as a party-goer and has to
change his his life entirely in order to
recover from this and
you know this type of behavior for
someone in the real world someone who
doesn't have the money that jon jones
does doesn't have the fame and notoriety
that jon jones does this type of
behavior leads to jail time leads to
death leads to other people he was some
normal black man out in the world of
america he's [ __ ]
oh a hundred percent so my thing is this
is like if he is to move on from this it
has to be a complete and utter spiritual
and mental psychological change
from from where he has to go from there
the second so so the second part i want
to talk about is
what determines
whether someone is a good man or a bad
man
based on their actions how many actions
does it take
is redemption possible all the time
doesn't does redemption become harder to
to get
uh the more you [ __ ] up
and that's that's what i'm curious about
someone like jon jones is like i even
though
this position that he's in right now
even though i still like to think that
there's a
potential for redemption at least within
himself
how old's jon jones
i'm not i'm not entirely sure he has 33
[ __ ] four bro
there's no there is no time for him to
turn his life around
and come back how many chances is this
guy being given
didn't he get he got popped for some
sort of pds like if you want to tick off
all of the big things that you shouldn't
do as an athlete whether it's
recreational whether it be performance
enhancing drugs whether it be getting
into misdemeanors he
hit a pregnant woman in his car he shot
a gun outside of the window of one of
his cars he was belligerent to the
police when he got arrested this time
after this incident with his misses and
he had the cuffs on behind his back
apparently turned to the four police
officers and said i'd love to see if you
four like [ __ ] could take me on your
own if you undid these handcuffs i've
just been inducted into the hall of fame
then he headbutted the police car so
he's now got to pay for the damages to
the police car so like the guys
what i'm saying of course what i'm
saying is though is like that whole
being a fighter thing is gone like in my
opinion to be an uh to come back maybe i
mean who knows in this weird world we
live in
you know like o.j simpson is one step
away from getting a celebrity boxing
match like that's how [ __ ] weird this
world is is he okay i don't know you
know okay it's like you never know what
can happen you know what i'm saying
though right like
jake paul logan paul all this stuff
they're they're headliner they're
they're big martial artists now like
it's it's crazy
i was thinking more along the lines of
like jon jones just disappears
just disappears out of the limelight
and changes who he is
in order to survive in this world as far
as i'm wondering
that's already happened so people
mentioned this they said a few years ago
jon jones could lord it over people like
danny because one of the reasons that he
said he wasn't going to come back is
because he wanted to get paid a million
dollars for a fight and the ufc
don't seem to be quite good with fight
to pay that's a big criticism that they
often get
so john said i'm going to wait because i
can hold out because i can negotiate he
forgets man this fought this sport moves
so fast they don't [ __ ] need jon
jones anymore the sport doesn't need him
they haven't needed him in the
heavyweight division for a long time and
he continues to [ __ ] up and continues to
be out of the game
so
i i don't see where his leverage comes
from with regards to that i don't think
that people care i don't think the ufc
need him i don't think the world need
him like if you're not going to be a
good athlete what you can be is a good
ambassador or a good role model for
people to look up to young kids you know
let's say the cormiers of the world like
yeah cowboy is another is another
surrounding [ __ ] khabib the guy
retired at the peak of his career so
he's no longer an athlete in the mma uh
in the ufc but he can be a really good
ambassador for people to look up to jon
jones has [ __ ] both of those things
he's no longer an athlete yeah and he's
not a a role model for people to look up
to i don't want my future kids to be
looking up to jon jones as the sort of
athlete that they should try and aspire
to be [ __ ] that so yeah in terms of that
correct and then in terms of how much
redemption you need
how much you would need to do to undo
all of the bad work
i don't think anyone can
i don't i would always try and give
somebody the opportunity to try and
achieve redemption i don't think that
anybody can be a lost cause apart from
like psychopaths and people that are in
prison and rapists and stuff like that
yes and that's what i mean is like
i think a lot of times people want
redemption fast because that's how the
world works now
right it's like i want to be back in the
limelight but i want to be in your good
uh on your good side and what's missing
there is the penance what's missing
there is the shame
and given what given jon jones's past
that shame and that penance that that
has to take years i mean i would say
this
chris as much as you would say there's
no possible way this man could redeem
himself
what about 10 years from now
what does her 10 years now
i don't i'm i'm not entirely sure and
that's why i i it's interesting to me i
like to talk about things like this
because these are things that are almost
outside of the scope of human nature is
like long-term
feelings about someone else
i have this feeling that
people want to be on the winning side
so
for instance if if you
[ __ ] up
i
want to naturally be on your side
outside of being my friend someone i
care about i want you to be on top of
whatever that is i want you to come out
on the on the good side of that because
it
i want to be a winner too you know it's
like and that's not like a it sounds
very self-indulging but i'm not trying
to be it's like
i think people want redemption i think
people want kind of you mean you they
want people to achieve redemption
i think so so i think so you may be
right man but there's only so many times
that you can of course let that happen
you know the cheating boyfriend in the
relationship
the wife might be able to take him back
the first time or the second time or
whatever but after
five times you go
this isn't a misdemeanor that requires
redemption this is an inbuilt part of
your nature
this is just you
and here's another thing i think that
where you're coming at this from is
maybe the same as me which is
an inherent belief that people are good
an inherent hope that people are here to
try and be good people like to
contribute to society in a way that's
[ __ ] constructive and leave the world
in a better place than they found it
i think we need to concede that there
are some people out there who don't do
that like there are some people who
simply if you leave them in the world
for long enough they're going to
continue to make it a worse and worse
and worse place
yeah and like the
the crazy thing about all this is like
this position that i'm playing right now
it's just a position that i'm curious
about i'm thinking through it
this is not how you know what i mean and
i just want the listeners and viewers to
kind of understand that
i i
like to think about things from from a
lens that i may not think about in real
life you know when it happens
i've been [ __ ] over you've been [ __ ]
over i'm sure both of us have [ __ ]
over some people
um and
they have every right and you have every
right and i have every right to move on
from that person
um
but i still like to think about the
potential for someone to make some sort
of a comeback and you know this is just
a thought cause like
jesus jon jones really has [ __ ] up the
most
of anyone in his sport
that i could even think of here's a
question for you
is it still acceptable to call jon jones
the goat when he behaves privately
in the way that we've seen can you
separate the art and the artist
no i i i never called him that
and basically because of that
so you think that you know joe rogan had
you know
it's
it's very weird now we're talking about
morality and
ability all right so fighting talent in
the in the octagon is either greatest of
all time
well
i don't i don't know
possibly
it would it would be
between him
i think khabib
uh we're looking at valentina chefchanko
who's doesn't seem like she's gonna lose
anytime soon
who else would be on that list
a lot of it has to do with title
defenses i think that's one of the
criticisms that khabib gets right that
who did he fight that he did a title
defense against that was actually world
class whereas jon jones pretty much
everyone that he did a title defense
against was world class
right
um and then also
conor mcgregor didn't have many title
defenses if any did he have any none
right i think that was his main
criticism too
but
um yeah you know i
i don't know is just very very strange
and and the whole thing is eerie dude
it's just like
something needs to change like what what
would you do if you were john jones's
friend if he has any friends i don't
even
i think i would have given up by now
yeah i think that i get quite personally
invested in my friends and in their
well-being right and after a while after
it depends how long if you've only just
become friends with him this week then
maybe you've got a bit of tolerance left
in the tank
but yeah i would have um
right
there's only so far that you can try and
take people and it's like like man like
this is your [ __ ] i would have tried to
have an intervention i would have tried
to sit down with him i'd try to do
whatever it seems very much like he's
hugely narcissistic like he has very
little empathy for other people oh of
course yeah and with all of those things
piled together it's like look man this
is your [ __ ] problem if you're big
enough to hit a woman you're big enough
to get yourself out of all of these
messes that you got yourself into
so
yeah anyway here's here's one for you
here's another one so uh new zealand is
divided over the all-white name change
you seen this
no
a heated debate is raging in new zealand
after the country's football governing
body said it was considering changing
the nickname of the men's national team
new zealand football has revealed that
the all-white name could be changed in
order to avoid racist connotations
the sports governing body has confirmed
that it was reviewing the name setting
the scene for arguments between the old
school traditionalists and those who
value inclusivity many new zealand
sporting sides have colour-based
nicknames the men's cricket side are the
black caps the men's basketball side are
the tall blacks however non-rankle like
the all-whites which can be read to mean
excluding other ethnicities the question
of the name change comes as many new
zealand organizations adopt names and
identities that incorporate maori
culture and language the police chief
sorry the police chief football chief
said that the
sporting body was on a journey around
cultural inclusivity we are working on a
process with stakeholders across the
game as well as people from outside
football looking at all areas of the
organization to make sure they are fit
for purpose in 2021 and beyond
uh one of new zealand's greatest ever
players wynton roofer a proud maori man
and a member of the 1982 team that they
got their
name from said changing the all white's
name was quote absolute madness the all
blacks brand is iconic and this is no
different
okay so this is the first time i've ever
heard of the name the all whites me too
i don't think new zealand are
particularly good at football
right so that's what i was like the
always what i know the all blacks
because they're
legendary literally one of the greatest
dynasties in all of sport um
you know there's been a lot of changes
in america with american football
um
with
many other teams and their logos
and it's just redskins and stuff yeah
the redskins now i don't know what
they're this is pathetic but i think
they're just like the washington
football team or something like that
that's what the best name ever yeah yeah
um and then you know the indians had
that old logo which was like the smiling
native american guy the newest name is
the washington football team
yeah is that is that what it is the
washington football team yep so then um
it also was the bullets they were
chained that was changed in
god the maybe the late 90s
2000 maybe what did that original mean
the bullets it was the washington
bullets and it was just a bullet logo it
was cool
uh
violence crime violence okay so so then
now they're the uh washington wizards
it's a basketball team
um there's plenty of different things
like that and
i don't know it can be argued both ways
a red skin is pretty tough man it's hard
to
you know that is a slang
that is a slang term that's a derogatory
term um
but it depends
you know who are you offending and are
they offended and that's the real
question the question would be whether
or not an all-whites versus an all
blacks and a black caps and a tall
blacks
like that's this is the theme that new
zealand have going between all of their
different sports teams all blacks the
rugby if you change one you gotta change
them all right
well no by that logic there's an
inherent punching up versus punching
down
like perspective that's being used that
somehow all blacks is inclusive but all
whites isn't and i don't know man it
just feels like
can we not try
to keep
race dynamics
out of
sport as much as possible i'm aware that
sport is a good opportunity to display
to people like look
this is a very diverse team that we have
on the field and this is a young working
class
asian guy white guy black guy whatever
guide that comes up through the ranks
and you can be like that person like
individual players and their teams at
large are awesome role models for young
kids and for older people as well
but
like when you've got an entire country's
set of sporting teams named after the
tall blacks and the black caps and the
all blacks like the all-whites being the
one that gets singled out
it sounds like men over the age of 40
should be getting vasectomies it just
sounds like
that again
it's as ridiculous in your mind
maybe not quite but
it's obviously
it's obviously stupid
like to to do that
highlights and asymmetry
right
yeah no i mean that's what i was saying
is is if if they
determine that one is bad they have to
determine all of them are bad because
they're all along the same line
right all of the the all whites the tall
blacks the blacks
you know
it's
what it is
what about people what sport would they
be playing
i don't know what are short people good
at
wrestling i think okay
yeah so the new zealand wrestling the
short blacks or the short whites yeah
yeah i honestly that's the first time
i've ever heard of the all whites well
no for sure now you've heard of it what
do you think about nfts
don't know enough about them and have
not
i don't know anything me neither but
like everyone everyone seems to be
talking about him everyone's doing them
do you know anything about them because
that'll be more than me
i kind of understand that it's a way to
uh create individual pieces of typically
artwork on the internet that can be
owned and licensed by a person so it
would be the equivalent of you buying a
piece of art in the real world or a
particular file uh typically these are
illustrations or like images
and people purchase them but you are a
verified owner and you can limit the
number that there are
um and you use smart contracts in the
blockchain and stuff to be able to
to go whoa
so it's mainly around art at the moment
it seems like that's what it's mostly
being used for but people can do it with
anything
right because so you're buying the
rights to the art buying the rights to
the sale of the art then kind of because
digitally
the physical presence of the art can be
everywhere right like i can have a
screenshot of it you can have a
screenshot of it right but in the nft
non-fungible tokens world only one
person can actually own the piece of art
which is licensed via a smart contract
through the blockchain
okay
so it's a way for digital artists to
make bear money but it's the same here's
the thing right
i would love to know how many people
that adore
nfts
love
the platform and the technology and how
many of them love the fact that they can
make tons of money off it so we spoke
about this last time about yeah
like do you love the fact that people in
war-torn countries can send money back
to their grandma without the state
overreach stopping them from doing it
or do you like the fact that it doubles
every couple of years yeah it's the
latter it's the latter of the two every
single time
and the beauty of it is that it's
guilt-free for right now at least right
why is it guilt-free
well because
i don't think anyone's really calling
people out for for doing something as
selfish as
just playing this weird money game
uh and
and making money out of it people you
got called out by a man with a moustache
oh mark ripito
yeah
well okay so if are we do we want to
dive into this i want to know about the
man with the moustache
okay so this is for for people listening
this is a
it's almost a silly kind of internet
beef but we'll dive into it because it
does get a little bit interesting it
starts off about a year and a half ago
my profession my expertise is in the
sport of olympic weightlifting
so
a year and a half ago this guy named um
mark ripenzo he's the creator of
starting strength and his book has
reached almost a million copies sold
uh it is like
you know a guideline to barbell training
to get stronger and
you know i think at the timing of which
he came out with the book and
started to build his youtube channel and
content it was timed very very well
we're we are now in an era where
there's a lot more people
with
good uh if not better information than
starting strength
uh but he was one of the originals and
he got people stronger and that's very
important to understand
he was talking about olympic
weightlifting in
uh
one of his podcasts a year and a half
ago and he he kept uttering the same
thing that he always talks about
throughout this and it's that
weightlifting coaches or powerlifting
coaches they don't know what they're
talking about
and
there's always this
idea there's always this feeling that
yes he's trying to get beginners
stronger he will outwardly say i don't
care about professional athletes i don't
care about elite performance but at the
same time he will say those who are
coaching elite performance or those who
are doing things illegally they don't
know what they're doing
and so
he said that about weightlifting and i
ended up writing a comment and then he
did a comments from the haters that's
one of his segments and he said my
comment or he he read it out loud
so a year later i'm like you know what i
forgot about this thing i made a video
and it kind of exploded a little bit
uh basically talking about the things
that mark ripito had said that i
disagreed with
then he made another clip
which was very egregious where he laid
out almost exactly
what i had issues with word for word in
a very
just very clear-cut way and so all i did
was then make another video and disagree
with it
what he said precisely
okay so there's a man named lasha tal
hadza
li just performed
the greatest snatch of all time the
snatch is moving the barbell from the
floor to overhead he did it with 223
kilograms
this man has broken the world record
which has been his own
god knows how many times okay i believe
the world record when he started
was
217 and he's the one who's broken it six
times now
okay this is the this is
simply the greatest snatch ever
and mark ribento said
well you know his technique could have
been better from our standpoint but it
doesn't matter because the snatch is 50
percent of your deadlift
uh and and technique doesn't matter
those are the words directly out of his
mouth
then later he says
uh
later he says the reason why some of
these old records haven't been broken is
because weightlifting coaches don't know
what they're talking about from a
technical and a training standpoint
so for those of you listening
both of those things couldn't be more
clear cut contextual evidence as to what
i disagree with wholeheartedly
okay so i made another video
and boom he
sees this
makes another video retorting me calling
me a [ __ ] child so this time he just
goes off a [ __ ] child my viewers uh
he said are [ __ ] idiots he said i've
sold one million books what have you
done i've gotten more people strong than
you i've invented all of this different
stuff so at this point the saga is over
because his comment section is just
attacking him
you know what i mean it's it's one of
those things where
we could have kept this stupid internet
beef going on and on and on but i just
let
let him kind of defeat himself when did
men's health write the article
right so
that's where this gets even more
ridiculous men's health okay so for
everyone listening
that all everything i just said doesn't
mean anything to you right but if men's
health starts to pick up this maybe it
will
okay because men's health is a proper
publication it's not just some random
youtube channel
i see that men's health is doing a
report on this
beef
however they refuse to use my name both
men's health and um mark ribito refuse
to use my name because they feel as
though i'm going to
gain clout from this and this is exactly
what i want
right that's another one of their
arguments is like they just want clicks
that's why they're going after us like
no actually i just disagree with you and
i already get more clicks than you
i get more views i get more clicks than
you that video which you called me out
has the most clicks of any of your
videos in the past six months
because i it was about myself and my
viewers went to your channel
but that's it that's the whole story it
was just hilarious to wake up one
morning and see men's health was
covering this [ __ ] internet beef
about a weightlifting coach
and some random old strength coach what
was that comment where someone said
what's all of this weightlifting stuff
doing on my white supremacy channel
so mark ripito is like the most texas
old just like
hard
man okay
he's got a great accent
he says things like why
right instead of why he says why and
what
type of stuff so
um
he kind of has his own like little meme
lords which i really respect like his
own meta content people uh but he's more
of like a libertarian obviously right
leaning and uh someone commented it was
like
what is all this weightlifting [ __ ]
[ __ ] doing on my libertarian
uh like right-leaning militia podcast
and i thought that [ __ ] was so funny man
i thought that was so funny
but yeah that's what i've been involved
in and the thing is like you and i
talked about this i had men's health
covering it right
and
you were like dude you're sitting on a a
pot of gold here you have to go and make
a video you had to
after you said that though i went and
checked on his video and all the
comments were like negative taking my
side
so i was like you know what i kind this
did the job for me just i don't need to
yeah how noble of you see jon jones
could learn a thing or two from you
just [ __ ] let it go john
right right do you want to do you want
to learn about orgasms
yes
yes boy do i ever i thought you'd never
ask me too so uh
i looked at a study accounting for
women's orgasms and sexual enjoyment in
college hookups and relationships so
this looked at investigated the
determinants of orgasm and sexual
enjoyment in hookup and relationship sex
among heterosexual college women and
seeks to explain why relationships uh
sex is better for women in terms of
orgasm and sexual enjoyment we found
that women have orgasms more often in
relationships than in hookups regression
analysis reveal that specific sexual
practices experience with a particular
partner and commitment all predict
women's orgasm and sexual enjoyment the
presence of more sexual practice
conducive to women's orgasm in
relationship sex explains some of why
orgasm is more common in relationships
uh there is also a double standard
contributing to why relationship sex is
better for women both men and women
question women's but not men's
entitlement to pleasure in hookups but
believes strongly in women's as well as
men's entitlement to pleasure in
relationship more attention is thus
given to producing female orgasm in
relationships but not in hookups and
here's the stats so if you've had no
prior hookups with this partner 11
orgasm one or two prior hookups with
this partner 16 orgasm
three plus prior hookups
34
and six plus months of a relationship 67
yeah and um i i almost know the reason
why it's like
when you are first getting into some
sort of relationship whether it be
physical
whether you have the intention of going
further there is the
you have to kind of hide your cards you
you have to as a guy
both women and men
and the discussion around sex
is still a mystery it's like you kind of
have this thing where if you're gonna
hook up with someone you're like oh man
i still have to like make this move at
this time and i can't just outwardly say
okay so now we're gonna have sex now can
you tell me exactly what pleasures you
and can you you know what i mean like
that's that's not the the level of
discussion but as you get into a
relationship you're damn near [ __ ]
in front of your girlfriend
right and your girlfriend is you know
doing everything like you guys there's
no filter so at that point she could be
like hey you know do this exact thing
and we're both going to have a party in
here it's going to be great yeah that to
me that seems like the only logical
reason yeah so it said the um
the presence of more sexual practice
conducive
uh experience with a particular partner
and commitment as well was another one
so i wanted to dig into this more so i
read that yeah like this is pretty
interesting so i want to find out what
causes women to enjoy
sex more uh again
from this very rigorous bro science
study that i've been doing and what got
me on to it was i was chatting to a
bisexual girl actually who's just come
out of a relationship
with her first relationship with a girl
and she said to me
making a girl orgasm feels like quite an
achievement i can see why men enjoy it
but what that highlighted was that for
girls making a man come is just like
well it's it's gonna happen like if i
just keep pumping away
yep it's gonna happen just keep pumping
you know
and and then it it happens in the end
whereas with a girl there's more
intricacies going on right so this is
[ __ ] fascinating man the influence of
types of stimulation and attitudes to
clitoral self-stimulation on female
sexual and orgasms satisfaction a
cross-sectional study so long and short
of it
is
long and short of it is that girls on
the whole
see any type of orgasm that involves
using the clitoris as a second standard
it's like a second class quality
for it okay which is pretty crazy so
whether women experience orgasms depends
mainly on the type of sexual activity
direct stimulation of the clitoris
improves the regularity of experienced
orgasms called orgasm consistency and
orgasm quality during sexual intercourse
without direct clitoral stimulation
only about one-third of females
experience an orgasm in contrast during
masturbation 59 of women usually
experience an orgasm blah blah blah blah
blah forward and back forward and back
women who orgasm more frequently
reported a higher awareness of their
bodily sensations more erotic fantasies
during intercourse more variation in
their sexual behavior and higher
emotional intimacy so emotional intimacy
comes back to the relationship thing
again yeah many women
yeah go ahead sorry many women who have
difficulties experiencing an orgasm
report psychological strain and low
satisfaction with their sexual
relationship a low orgasm frequency is
related to cognitive distraction high
automatic thoughts suppression of erotic
thoughts pressure to perform and sexual
myths so
overall here it says that
orgasm consistency through sexual
intercourse had a stronger influence on
orgasm satisfaction and sexual
satisfaction than orgasm consistency
through oral sex stimulation by the
partner's hand or self-stimulation this
is surprising since many women even
describe an orgasm as more pleasurable
when stimulated directly by the clitoris
and female orgasms least likely to be
caused by this type of stimulation
although there is no biological
difference between a vaginal and a
clitoral orgasm many women seem to
desire orgasms through purely vaginal
penetration the results indicate that
the common misconception about sexuality
that it is normal for women to
experience orgasms during penile vaginal
intercourse influences the subjective
evaluation of one's own sexuality
orgasms from clitoral stimulation seem
to have a second class quality for some
women while there is no evidence that
these orgasms feel less pleasurable
right because
it would seem as though the clitoral
stimulation is almost like a hack
right it's like you get your vibrator
you go right for it
you have the images in your brain or you
watch porn it just you get it done
and if they can
kind of teleport themselves to wherever
they need to be while sex is happening
and they get clitoral stimulation they
can almost do exactly the same thing
that they were doing you know during
masturbation uh
but
the purely
would is it vaginal yeah purely vaginal
um one would mean that their connection
with
whomever it is that they're hooking up
with
was so strong that it didn't require
that you can't walk your way out of it
yeah and i think that yeah what was
really [ __ ] interesting was the talk
about cognitive distraction automatic
thoughts suppression of erotic thoughts
pressure to perform and sexual myths so
the biggest
restriction
to girls
coming during sex
purely through penetrative sex
is their own mind
yes yes and
part of it is the you know all of the
things you listed above it's kind of the
trickle-down effect there's
the it's vulnerability
at the end of the day right i mean it's
why would i open myself up completely
carnally like everything to this person
if they're going to leave me
right it's it's like that's almost what
it requires
to have that level of an orgasm and for
women who like
and again this is
speaking of someone who's like sure of
themselves right but i'm a [ __ ] bro
and like like trust me i'm aware
um but i'm i'm working through this
because this is very interesting you
know and it also takes
it takes experience on both ends like
i've had my
experience and frustrations and
successes
um but what i
what i can ultimately say is like
that
i i wonder
where masturbation for women plays into
all of this because i know for a fact
that masturbation on the men's side what
with using with the use of porn
um and like your own hand that can
affect your sexual stimulation and
there's been actually a lot there's this
huge meta analysis um that i want to
show you i didn't don't i obviously was
not prepared for this discussion
uh but there's a huge meta-analysis
talking about um porn and its effects on
male stimulation uh you know in order to
like the inability to have an erection
sustain an erection expectation and then
how it affects the relationship
so it can cause relationship breakups it
can cause divorce it can be a catalyst
to cause breakups it can be a catalyst
to cause divorce and i wonder
the female side of that
right because i
when i end up trying to get uh close
with a female i actually ask them these
things about masturbation about these
things because it's like one i'm curious
and two it's like i
i can't judge i'm not gonna judge you
you know what i mean it's not we are we
live in a different time where
you know back in the 50s 60s 70s like no
one talks about masturbation no one
talks about sex i want you to get there
i want to know about how asking a girl
her masturbation technique intricacies
how it comes about on a first date i
want to know how that goes yeah not on
the phone how many days how many dates
you need to go
look i've i've gotten it on the first
date to talk about it you know because
it's like i'm open about whatever it's
it's hard for them you know
i don't want to make the person
uncomfortable so the conversation is the
first place i go to masturbation yeah no
no the conversation i go to is following
their lead
right i'm not going to push any further
because there's nothing i hate more than
like making the person sitting across me
feel awkward and
that you have to build that trust
overcome conversation obviously
and more likely than not on a first date
you're going to end up talking about
relationships are you not
what you know because you want to know
about the person who you know who have
you dated what was wrong with it what
was what did you do wrong what did they
do wrong what do you like what don't you
like and it if you're not talking about
sex at that point
right at some point you have to start
talking about sex if you talk about sex
you talk about
people not being good at sex or you talk
about people being good at sex what they
did that was good and then
masturbation habits end up having to be
discussed
right i just kind of bro science walked
you through exactly how that's why
that's why you're doing it okay so
i think bro science time i think that
the pressure to perform and the sexual
myths which are two of the four reasons
for low orgasm frequency according to
this study pressure to perform comes
from um
what they predict the partner expects
from them
and because of how much porn is around i
think that that probably will have made
girls believe that they need to act in a
certain way i have seen some studies
saying that
um more men and women believe that
anal sex should happen because it like
just happens in porn so therefore it
porn is a representation of intimacy
that happens in the normal world and
then the sexual myths thing is about the
fact that in most porn it looks like
girls do orgasm
through sex
so
the girl themselves feels oh well this
myth is part of me now i don't know how
much of a myth thing it is because when
it's self-created
through
the girls on rumination and automatic
thoughts and suppression and blah blah
blah
that's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
that's like your the thing that you want
to have happen
you're stopping it from happening
because of how badly you want it to
happen
uncomfortable situation
that's i mean that's essentially right
like what's the one thing that men face
is ability to get it up yeah
you know and then the thought process of
trying to get it up makes it worse
don't think about it
babe don't think about it it'll just
happen okay you don't want me to think
about it now now all i can do is think
about it yeah right so it's kind of the
same thing if a woman wants to have an
orgasm and you and like you know that's
all they're thinking about and then they
think oh crap well i'm not it's not i'm
doing it right is it happening right is
he enjoying it am i enjoying it should i
be doing this
yes yes that's such a good analogy
yeah and i mean i i saw i think it was
someone on rogan a while back
but this guy was saying
you know there's a mixture of drugs you
can take to where you just let go of
everything and it's uh it's like a
i think it's it would it be called
oxytocin i know that oxytocin is what's
released i know that but is there like a
form of that
something like was this for women or for
guys this was
someone on rogan's podcast was like yo
i've got this combination and you gotta
try it and it was like facebook
something and ketamine
like it's a very my yes for sex a very
mild dose of ketamine in a very mild
dose of like oxytocin or something like
that
oh and then yeah he was also saying you
can rub something directly on your dick
this sounds like ben greenfield this
sounds like very very ben greenfield
okay it could it could have honestly
been him i don't remember but i remember
the comments being like yo this guy is
[ __ ] insane for suggesting for
suggesting people going out of their way
to get some ketamine from like some
random [ __ ] you know by the way
all of these drugs are illegal you know
but drugs are
well discussed on rogan um but i
i it's one of those things take yourself
out of your brain and be present it's
very there's a limit though
there's a limit to taking yourself out
of your brain like if i if i have enough
ketamine i'm not on the same planet
anymore
you're not having sex with bro
i'm trying to get out into the astral
plane right you know that's where i am
i'm trying to get out and look be above
the bed while we're [ __ ] i wanna
you know
like in like in that movie with um you
just get shoved into the astral plane
i'm just saying
benedict cumberbatch was trying to get
all of his skills so that he could have
sex in the astral plane
yes exactly yes i'm glad we're in
agreement
yeah
um
one one thing i want to talk about and
actually dude i could talk about that
stuff all day so
that was very interesting but um one
thing i want to talk about my friend
uh ian
ian daniel we know him as ian the rhino
uh he's a he's a very strong dude power
lifter he has a background in crossfit
so he went to the crossfit games twice
as a team athlete
um and he went to like legit
games it wasn't like early on these were
very hard to qualify he's a very
very you know accomplished individual
and uh let's see i'm gonna pull up the
the quote here because this is really
interesting
where are we at chris williamson there
we go
and
crossfit games posted a picture
of a woman athlete and i gotta find out
what her name is vicky caruso
and in this picture
she honestly looks like
a single digit body fat
on top of that she has to perform these
athletic feats and these feats of
strength so she did a 280 pound clean
which is a little bit under
uh 130 kilos for a female that is insane
okay for
an average gym going male that's as high
as you're gonna get
okay and she has single digit body fat
she has
unbelievable leg veins ab definition
and she has
you know it just doesn't seem
legit and the post that crossfit games
posted it was kind of like a repost
i want to pull it up
because the reason i bring ian up is
that they um
they
took his comment down
and his comment was the highest rated it
had the most comments and it was about
the drug use and the pe d use in a sport
like crossfit god i can't even find i
can't even find the original post
because they posted so many times or
they might have to oh here it is right
here
so
this is what vicky caruso had said
uh naturally the steroid comments come
out these comments don't even bother me
anymore i've been hearing about that
stuff since i was 10 years old
really
you've been hearing about steroid abuse
since you were 10 years old that
there's no way and my legs
uh my legs were more defined than most
professional bodybuilders
and then all throughout running track in
college i was randomly chosen for drug
tests
it doesn't bother me
because i had nothing to hide and i
still don't anyone who knows me knows
that i'm a huge advocate for more drug
testing
what bothers me is the fact that when
people see someone do something they
can't do especially in the world of
fitness they automatically assume
they're taking something
i follow a fellow i follow a lot of
fellow athletes and every time i see
someone hit a big lift or do something
impressive i'm happy for them i've never
once thought oh they're juicing because
they're doing something i can't
if it comes out a couple months later
that they were on
that
that they were on then joke's on me but
until then let's start celebrating
people's successes uh we need to be
positive and supportive of each other
and stop comparing people okay so
if you look at this woman's profile
and you should definitely flash some of
these pictures on screen
there is some crazy
uh definition stuff that you would see
on bodybuilders and it is possible it is
absolutely possible to diet down and get
everything perfectly if you are
genetically
capable of having that level of
definition and vascularity it is
possible for her to do that
single thing naturally now is it
possible for her to do that
and clean 130 kilos
i would say no
and it would point me
in the in the direction of saying no so
this is where my friend ian says this
the idea that crossfit is a natural
sport
at the most elite levels is literally
the biggest non-truth told to its
audience that is this is coming from a
previous two times game competitor
i'm tired of it it's disingenuous to
sell that idea to gen pop the use of
peptides and fast clearing steroid
hormones is rampant and kept quiet
i literally know of previous reebok
sponsored athletes who popped and were
never disclosed because it would hurt
the brand's image
too much of fit
too much of fitness makes money off of
using their elites to mislead people
into what kinds of results are realistic
through natural dieting and training
cleaning 280 as a female with what
appears to be single digit body fat
sorry that's not how female that's not
how natural female physiology works now
when i took a screenshot of this he had
227 likes on this um which was
you know 50 times the next highest liked
one
and
i came back to it a couple hours later
and there was 400 likes then i came back
to it a couple hours later and it was
gone
okay the the number one liked thing the
number one opinion on this was taken
down
obviously by crossfit games themselves
um
so it's it's
it's interesting that you have a
a business
that wants to be considered a legitimate
clean and fair sport
uh when in reality they would never ever
want to negatively affect their business
by popping one of their own athletes
but they popped ricky gerard
yeah and to me i think you know that
could have been the
sacrificial lamb
so for those listening ricky gerard got
third at the games
um whenev whatever year that was the
crossfit games
and 2007. then they yeah and then they
ended up retroactively
uh popping him fr for psarms or he
tested positive there
now
a lot of people have been saying that
that was a sacrificial lamb to say that
crossfit's like look we popped a guy
who's who was third place
you know who was on the podium
but it's ricky gerard no one knows who
the hell he is matt fraser you know rich
frohning uh any of the women tia claire
toomey whatever it is maybe they're on
maybe they're not but
boy if they ever tested positive they
would never do anything
you think i mean
oh yeah if rich froning
i mean
for me all signs point to a lot of these
guys using i'll never know why we will
never know because why is because
the game is recovery so crossfit
especially them it is a sport where
recovery could not be more important
than anything else because you have to
every single day do things that require
mainly work capacity work there are
certain things that that are like snatch
clean and jerk you know a single rep of
each but for the most part we see 10 to
20 minute workouts where work capacity
is being tested and it's not entirely a
skill based sport and i would say that
about many different um
you know many different olympic sports
you know it's not the to me the skill
that the hard aspect of sports is
adapting to certain stimulus
when you need to rugby you have to make
a move
because you're
it's determined by your opponent um you
have to change no two movements are the
same ever in rugby it's all about what
you can do with your mind it takes a lot
of skill in that way in crossfit
they literally for one of the events
took a bunch of sandbags
brought them from one end of the arena
to a wheelbarrow they wheeled them
across to the other side of the arena
and then they took those sandbags and
walked them up the stairs
just to show that this sport is about
capacity we are testing capacity who is
capable of doing the most work for the
most and there's crossfit is just an
accelerator and learning how hard to
press the accelerator and and who can do
that the most efficiently and the best
and there's nothing wrong with that but
that leads me to believe that honest to
god
anabolics and androgens couldn't work in
a
couldn't work better in any sport
they would benefit a crossfitter more
than
most other sports
androgens could benefit them because of
the recovery aspect of it because it's
pure
gas pedal it's pure motor it's pure
engine whereas
uh you know what here's another one
cycling
but see that's cycling
if it's the multiple day efforts yeah
cycling is very similar recovery low
skill
low skill just effort just go
you know you have to think about when
you're going to do something when you're
going to move whatever but for the most
part it's just who can recover the most
yeah i think strategy and skill are two
slightly different
techniques
like you can have your strategy in your
mind and that doesn't mean you're not
skilled at what you do but yeah i um
didn't
didn't matt fraser say on rogan wasn't
his excuse i don't know if steroids
would help
didn't he say that i don't think he said
that i don't think i've heard someone
use that maybe it was brent fakowski
i've heard something i mean
yeah steroids
they they damn near help with everything
literally everything
so the problem that crossfit has is it
it's like the ufc back in the day where
it's got an internal
yes and people want to [ __ ] on usada and
they can you know but for the most part
look at look at the size of the man in
the ufc now look at look at the body
types in the ufc now it is noticeably
different dude
like the single digits ufc ufc 7 or
something
yeah and that's the thing is like you
know yeah sure they're probably doing
peptides they're probably doing um
you know fast clearing steroids but it's
not at the level of what it used to be
and that's better
um crossfit right now it's like
dude i don't
i don't know i don't know how it works
it's very confusing
you know if they got usada involved that
could be very cool i think they'd be
very great but why would they do it what
would what why would they what's the
incentive for crossfit
that's the thing is what's the incentive
for even addressing this that's what i
would say chris is like why the [ __ ] did
crossfit even talk about this they
shouldn't have even brought it up it's
like
if they just stay silent if we're
talking purely business like yeah why
would they have usada on because it's
just business we're making money we're
doing well we're going up baby
but we're talking about morality here
okay so if we want to ignore morality
just don't even [ __ ] bring up
steroids
because that's what it is that's the
real discussion here is morality it's
here are the rules are you going to
break them in the name of what you think
is right or what is right
that's ultimately the question this is
something that my father spent most of
his years talking about
most of his career as a journalist has
talked about the morality of steroid use
because he covered the chicago cubs when
they had sami sosa and it was sami sosa
versus mark maguire
he he has had multiple cover stories on
sports illustrated about uh athletes
using he talks about it in the olympics
in in american football in baseball this
is what i've heard my entire life this
is not new to me and
what if if we are crossfit and we are
just a business
and we don't care about us being a
legitimate sport because when you are a
legitimate sport there is some sort of
morality contract that you have to sign
that's what the ufc realized if they
want to be treated like a legitimate
sport they have to get usada they have
to be
somewhat moral
it can't just be a wild wild west [ __ ]
show of a promotion where they just put
big guy versus small guy well they got
pride used to be big shareholders now
which
the crossfit doesn't crossfit's still a
private company yes and
and that's yeah they're the more
legitimate you try to make yourself this
is the thing is like people want to
ignore
uh they want the freak show they want
the jake paul fight
but at the end of the day i don't think
they really do
the the more legitimate you can make
whatever your platform
the more steps you have to take to
ignore business and and capitalistic
mindsets
crossfit as far as business goes and and
capital goes yeah it is not in their
best interest to get usada it costs a
lot of [ __ ] money to do that
and and for what
for what to lose but it's potentially a
big chunk of your game's roster
yeah or you know maybe things change
maybe
whatever it may be
but
part of it is we want to show that this
is a real sport you know and these are
the sacrifices you have to make the ufc
has done a lot over the years to be like
hey guys this isn't just some freak show
you remember when ufc was starting and
people were like this is archaic this is
disgusting this is like um
you know like most states still in
america don't allow ufc fights to happen
because it's just like it's too scary
it's too sketchy when really now it's
like everyone watches ufc even my dad
who thinks who used to think it was you
know uh too sketchy too too too rough um
now he watches it and that's because
they took that stance against drugs
i think that in order if crossfit wants
to make this argument where they're
being unfairly judged on the drug use in
it
they have to start making moves
so to repost that woman's post and say
hey a lot of us are getting critiqued on
steroid use when the reality is you
don't know what's going on it's like
well what are you doing to make us
believe that people are clean
nothing they're not doing anything
who would you say off the top roster if
you had to pick a couple of people that
were the highest likelihood of them
being on gear
who would you pick
i'll go first no
yeah this is the type of stuff that gets
you in trouble it gets you in trouble
i'm not in the fitness industry i don't
give a [ __ ]
you can pass you can pass if you want
i mean i said rich frohning i've i've
said that and the reason
i said rich phroning is the longevity
and the performance and the age
he's what 35 36 now
yeah and he's still crushing it
yeah
better than ever you know and it's not a
sport i think it i think it's one of
those things where it should be a sport
for the young
it is it should be
yeah [ __ ] so i was talking to
ben bergeron
about this
and he was saying that for this new
comp train academy
if you're over 26 they're not looking at
you
26
if you're older than 26 they're not
looking at you because it's going to
take a few years to develop you from
where you need to be and blah blah
it is a young person's sport because
it's about recovery
and
here's another that's why listen if it's
about recovery man androgens are being
[ __ ] used i will say that
honest to god
anyone who's listening who's a
crossfitter or who will listen and see
this as crossfitters like you have to be
skeptical and if it doesn't matter to
you then that's fine
if you think everyone's doping and it
doesn't [ __ ] matter fine that's great
but do not say that it's incredibly
likely that your hero your guy is not
taking or girl or female
either one no assurances until they get
a more robust testing procedure in place
there's no assurances that and even then
it's not it's not an assurance
it's not a for sure but it definitely
helps yeah it definitely helps usada is
a they are a bunch of nazis bro they
will [ __ ] you up if they do not give a
[ __ ]
they might not be able to catch you but
if they do catch you you're [ __ ]
they're not going to report to crossfit
and crossfit's going to determine your
outcome once you sign up with usada they
do whatever the [ __ ] they want game over
yeah there's no safe words there's no
way to get out of this alive yeah we got
to protect this guy no that's not the
case they're going to get you did you
see
that mark zuckerberg lost six billion
dollars
in a day
when facebook was down
listen man
if he takes my instagram away from me
once more
i don't know what i'm gonna do i think
if he does he should go bankrupt no i'm
kidding um that's that's the sort of
[ __ ] that's just it's
is it wrong that i feel good about it i
don't know so he went
on the world's richest list he dropped
from number two
i think sorry from number three to
number five so it's elon musk
210 billion jeff bezos 185 billion
bernard
arnold
[ __ ] knows who he is what's he doing
with all of these big names 153 billion
bill gates 124 mark zuckerberg the zuk
121 big
fat drop off mark zuckerberg's personal
wealth has fallen by more than six
billion dollars in a few hours knocking
him down a notch on the list of the
world's richest people after a
whistleblower came forward and outages
took facebook inks flagship products
offline a selloff sent the social media
giant stock plummeting 4.9 on monday
adding to a drop of about 15 percent
since september the stock sent sockslide
on monday sent zuckerberg's worth down
to 121.6 billion dropping him below bill
gates number five on the bloomberg
billionaires index he's down from almost
140 billion in a matter of weeks
according to the index
[ __ ] son
man
he's still got 121 billion dollars so
why i don't give a [ __ ] about mark
zuckerberg's personal wealth wealth
did you watch
have you been seeing the whistleblower
stuff that lady that came forward
about the pandora papers no
oh
facebook internal employee who's been
releasing all of these documents no i
haven't i haven't this is wild so
it's kind of it's weird because
everybody from the outside looking in
especially since what was that netflix
documentary about social media
oh god um [ __ ]
that one
yes since since that one uh came out
everyone's sort of known everyone's had
it in the back of their minds that look
this is this is pretty [ __ ] the
algorithms are manipulating us they're
telling us things they're changing our
behavior they're making us feel a
certain way
making people fearful limbic hijack
racing to the bottom of the brain stem
like all of this like [ __ ] who who's
surprised by this people like tristan
harris have been talking about this [ __ ]
for literally
four or five years publicly the
ex-design ethicist at google um but the
difference now i don't know why i don't
maybe it's just because
maybe i'm
overestimating or underestimating how
normy the normies are
like you have to be pretty [ __ ]
normie to not know that facebook and
whatsapp and instagram are doing this
sort of [ __ ] to people um yeah
but maybe i'm
maybe i'm giving them too much credit
but being aware of it does that make you
any better does that change your psyche
at all no but it wouldn't mean like i'm
not surprised this woman's come forward
and said
in the reports we have verifiable
information facebook's internal team has
information saying that instagram
actually hurts the body image of young
girls that it causes increases in
suicidal ideation that there is like a
they reckon that their
between three and five percent of global
conflict is due to facebook
they police
the platform
they managed to get a particular
percentage but they police almost all of
the comments and the content on the
platform in english and english only
accounts for nine percent of all of the
content that's produced on facebook so
overall what you end up with is
the world now being told through a
whistleblower
that
what people presumed for a very long
time and yeah already
engineered
that this was actually happening and
they're aware of it's like do you not
think they they see the [ __ ]
algorithms they make the algorithms like
yeah obviously they know that this is
going on we knew it was going on and we
don't have access to the algorithms but
obviously this was going to happen but
so yeah this lady's come forward and
basically said that there's a huge cache
of internal documents 10 000 pages that
she um siphoned off over a quite a long
time and then she left in may and
revealed them and these documents came
out and then she did a 60 minutes
interview which you can watch on youtube
and um then she gave a three hour
address to the house of congress or some
[ __ ] the other day as well and
yeah i mean it's a bad week
to be mark zuckerberg it's a it's a
pretty bad week
well okay the movie's called the social
dilemma that was it and and um you know
it's funny that like the whistleblower
comes out to say that water is wet
essentially
oh you know it causes you know young
females to negatively think about their
body wow shocker you know causes more
suicidal ideations shocker
you know this is all something that
people have been talking about for a
long time so why would you use
well because it's now from the people
that made it
it's coming directly from the people
that made it it's like uh you know if
anyone if anyone in politics if we
theorize that something has happened
and everyone theorizes it's like if
literally
um
what's his name i can um
epstein right
it's like if his prison guards
literally came out and said we killed
epstein
okay something we all knew
but now it's coming from
the mouth of the actual people that were
doing it
it's a little bit different
i think it's a little bit more you know
that might not be the best analogy but
you know what i mean it's coming
directly from the people that are
creating the algorithms that are
creating these problems
i don't know if it's better for facebook
to have the power of gods to be able to
manipulate the way that culture works
and if they were blind to it like what
what was the best that people could have
hoped for because the effect hasn't
changed
people we already knew that young girls
mental uh health was being impacted by
social media
that people were becoming addicted to
their devices that most people report
that in retrospect they wish they'd
spent less time on their phones so on
and so forth we knew that that was
happening
right
is it
what were we presuming before we saw
this document that facebook were like
culpably deniable willfully ignorant
like no they obviously in order to be
able to enact those those effects they
have to actually know the way that this
works
no and that's what i'm saying is like it
almost like skepticism and theory and
and
uh you know conspiracy theory like will
never ever be legitimate because it
doesn't make people like
people just always want to know
exactly if it is or if it isn't they
want to know no matter what they observe
they need to it needs to be declared
what it is and it's like yeah what did
we expect before was like no we didn't
expect anything different but we just
kind of went yeah you got to move on
right but now since it's legitimate
there's people saying oh yeah [ __ ] this
is a [ __ ] problem and they've known
it's been a problem but now it's like
okay you know it's it's like um you know
humans salivate over the potential to
have something be
cut and [ __ ] dry
you know because there's always this
dichotomy between good and bad
uh throughout everything
and people who are always running in
their brains to determine which side to
be on of any debate now it's like we are
sure
and it feels good
it feels really good to hate on mark
zuckerberg you know what i mean not as
good as it feels to hate on mark ripito
feels better
i look i don't hate on him i don't hate
on the man for real where can people go
to access your
alt-right libertarian youtube channel
just go to my youtube channel
zacktellender
z-a-c-k-space t-e-l-a-n-d-e-r
and um yeah you can go there and if you
guys want to learn how to weightlift go
to my patreon
patreon.com if you want to
watch me do more stuff go to my
instagram coach underscore zt and that's
it
easy we're out
you